في عام 2006 كموظف استقبال شاب في برج ترامب
رأيت السيد.  غالبًا ما يكون ترامب خارج
بنك المصعد السكني خارج
مجموعة Bay Rock Group الشركة التي عملت بها ،
وفي إحدى المرات عندما قدمت
نفسي له قبلني مرارًا وتكرارًا على
خدي وفي النهاية على شفتي ، الأمر الذي
كان صادمًا تمامًا وغير مناسب.
مندهشًا من أنه
وصفني بالكاذب ، أعني أن هذه
ليست المرة الأولى التي أظن أنه يهاجمني فيها
شخصيًا على Twitter ، لكن
نهجه كله كان ينفي
مزاعم نفسي ومثلما قال
ما يقرب من 20 امرأة لديهن  تعال ،
لذلك ليس من المستغرب ، لكنني أعتقد أنه
بصفتي رئيسًا سيكون لديه
أشياء أكثر أهمية للقيام بها من إرسال تغريدات
إلي ومحاولة تشويه سمعيتي ، وأنا أعلم
أنني أعرف ما هو صحيح هو يعرف ما هو
صحيح وأعتقد أنه يجب أن يخاف منها  الذي - التي